I hear you've built
the perfect safe house.
Well, what's this even made of?
Vibranium?
[CRASH]
[TRIUMPHANT MUSIC PLAYING]
[BOLLYWOOD MUSIC PLAYING]
An eerie stillness
chokes our lungs.
What are you doing?
You know you are
creeping us out.
You know that, right?
[BANG]
Oh, God.
Stay calm, please!
Chips.
It was just chips.
Thought you'd given up on humans.
I have a family now.
They give me faith again.
And I see the good in humanity
in them every single day.
These steam--
Engine.
I am sure you have
something simpler.
Simple.
Let's see-- ladies and
gentlemen, the plow.
[SPEAKING ANCIENT BABYLONIAN]
[CHEERING]
[SPEAKING HINDI]
I'm Karan Patel.
Kingo's valet. It's truly an
honor to be in the presence
of the great Eternals.
So, how did you end up
scoring this emerald tablet,
my beautiful, beautiful Makkari?
Did you miss me?
I'm sorry, what
are we watching
because-- are you two--
Is this new, because I hate it.
Who do you think is
going to lead the Avengers?
I could lead them.
Thor used to follow me around
when he was a little kid.
Now he's a famous Avenger
and won't return my calls.
[TRIUMPHANT MUSIC PLAYING]